[Música]
bueno pues
esta es mi abuela y siempre me contaba
historias y un día me estaba contando
una historia cerró el libro y me dijo
carlota los seres humanos estamos
dañando a la tierra y esto nos está
enviando mensajes pero no somos
conscientes de ello
luego me mira a los ojos y me pregunto
lo entiendes y todo lo que puede
responder en aquel momento fue abuela
solo tengo seis años desde siempre me
han encantado los animales de la
naturaleza pero no sería hasta años más
tarde que el mensaje de mi abuela
empezaría a tener sentido para mí
y
a medida que iba pasando mi vida
y tenía que ir a la universidad y pasé
la selectividad tenía que decir qué
carrera debía hacer y escogí
administración y dirección de empresas
porque eso tendría muchas salidas pero a
medida que iba pasando la carrera me di
cuenta de que eso no estaba hecho para
mí y a pesar de que muchos familiares me
recomendaron seguir a pesar de todo tuve
que decidir algo que nunca antes había
hecho salirme del camino algo para mí
totalmente revolucionario
así que al cabo de unos años
empecé a estudiar una carrera y empecé a
cuestionarme al principio absolutamente
todo en este impase o de que me gusta
que si mis actos diarios van acorde con
mis valores que vida quería llevar en un
futuro así que decidí estudiar algo que
me encantaba una carrera de ciencias
nutrición y dietética
a medida que me iba interesando más
sobre el tema me iba fijando en
diferentes cosas de mi vida un día
y va por la carretera y me crucé con un
camión lleno de cerdos hacinados
cubiertos en moratones y heridas y el
contraste entre eso y los animales
felices que vemos en todos los envases
de supermercado me impresionó muchísimo
porque era así porque nadie me lo había
dicho antes
estaba segura de que siguiéramos estos
animales entrando en los mataderos
muchísima menos gente se lo comería
así que fui al mejor lugar para
encontrar información precisa confiable
y basada en la evidencia youtube
vi un vídeo sobre una activista de los
derechos de los animales sensual man que
hablaba sobre
101 razones por las que deberíamos ser
veganos
y eso no sólo hizo que
dejará de comer animales y productos
derivados de la noche a la mañana sino
que fue lo que me convenció para hacer
algo bastante radical con mis propias
redes sociales al principio sólo
publicaba cosas por por diversión
sin más importancia
pero después de ver este vídeo no podía
quedarme igual así que decidí hacer algo
bastante radical con mis propias redes
sociales hice bueno decidí ir a una
granja industrial y un matadero
era imposible irse de allí con apetito
el olor a heces a sangre las heridas
infectadas las caras inundadas por el
miedo no me podía quedar de brazos
cruzados así que decidí publicar esa
visita
obviamente pensé que todo el mundo me
dejaría de seguir porque quién quiere
ver esas imágenes realmente nadie ni yo
tampoco pero sentía que debía hacerlo
por ellos así que casi que colgué el
post con los ojos cerrados y pensé es el
fin pero no fue así
en menos de 24 horas casi medio millón
de personas habían visto esa publicación
además que a día de hoy es la más vista
y la más compartida de todas mis redes
sociales
pero lo que más ilusión me hizo fue
mensajes de mis amigos más carnívoros
diciendo que se comprometían a cambiar
su manera de comer gracias a lo que
había compartido que fue como quitarse
una venda de los ojos
[Música]
pensé que a medida que me iba
interesando más sobre este tema y me iba
informando pensé que mi universidad
sería un gran lugar para obtener
respuestas y aunque en muchas ocasiones
lo fue en muchas otras parecía ignorar
por completo los problemas potenciales
que tienen la manera que comemos incluso
muchas de las voces que a las que
estuvimos expuestos tenían grandes
conflictos de intereses por ejemplo hay
grandes organizaciones
se dedican a promover la dieta
mediterránea considerada una de las más
saludables del mundo pero que luego
están patrocinadas por empresas que
elaboran de los peores productos ultra
procesados cárnicos e incluso empresas
de alcohol
así que en la ciencia también hay
lobbies que impiden que salga la verdad
a la luz pero por suerte cada vez más y
más meta-análisis que demuestran lo
importante y tremendamente eficaz que es
una alimentación vegetal tanto para
nuestra salud como para los animales y
para el planeta
y a medida que iba estudiando más sobre
los animales y la naturaleza me di
cuenta de que estamos en un momento de
crisis y esta crisis está dejando ver de
muchas maneras extinción de especies
temperaturas extremas incendios
inundaciones y al final los jóvenes nos
estamos dando cuenta porque nos toca
vivir en un momento donde tenemos que
aprender a ser un ser humano en una
tierra donde todos los sistemas vivos
están en declive y cada vez más rápido
así que leí todos los artículos que
puedes sobre la crisis climática
y también lo iba compartiendo todo en
mis redes sociales y al igual que con el
veganismo pensé que la gente querría
ponerse la venda de la ignorancia y
continuar con su vida como si nada
estuviera pasando pero no fue así la
gente quería saber más
y quizás estéis pensando que esto no
tiene mucho más alcance que las redes
sociales pero al final los usuarios de
las redes sociales tienen vidas reales y
lo que hacen influye tanto en su mundo
como en el mundo que les rodea y me di
cuenta de esto cuando la gente empezó a
pararme por la calle diciendo gracias a
lo que había compartido habían cambiado
su manera de comer y de iu de consumir
así que al final esto tiene un impacto y
las redes sociales tienen muchísimos
problemas pero también tiene un poder
incomparable en llegar a las personas
inspirar las a la acción
así que
siempre pienso en mi abuela y pienso
siempre ella tenía razón pero ahora solo
tiene la mitad de razón los humanos
seguimos dañando a la tierra pero cada
vez somos más conscientes de ello y
queremos ser parte del cambio estoy
segura y soy optimista de que algún día
estará totalmente equivocada pero estoy
segura de que no le importará en
absoluto gracias
[Aplausos]